Hey David, I'm curious, have you ever asked
to speak to the manager?
Are you one of those guys?
Uh, barely ever.
There are very, very few circumstances where
I have had to a lobby, a sort of a complaint
of some kind.
Uh, and when I do, I am really, really, really
polite partially because, um, it's happening
more and more that like, I'll go to a restaurant
and then when I'm leaving the restaurant,
someone will come up to me and say, hey, didn't
want to bother you while you were eating,
but love the show.
And it would be so embarrassing if I threw
a fit to a manager, uh, at a restaurant and
a viewer side and was horrified by it.
But in all seriousness, when I've had to lobby
a complaint, it's most often been either dealing
with airlines or dealing with hotels.
Those are the most common times that something
was truly wrong.
You know, a shower that, uh, leaked all over
the bathroom floor.
Okay, well that, that's gotta be dealt with.
Um, you know, I the, these are relatively
limited incidents, but when something like
that happens, I am always very polite to people
who are working often underpaid in a variety
of different jobs.
And one of the most cringe inducing things
for me socially is when I go out, it happens
most frequently at restaurants.
I go out to restaurants with people usually
that I don't know that well because I like
to think I don't closely associate with people
who treat wait staff poorly and someone starts
being rude to the wait staff.
It is a, an immediate red flag if that's how
you're treating in front of people you barely
know in public.
This is how you're treating people who are
underpaid, working in what are often not the
best environments depending on where it is
that they work and you're treating them like
that.
You're not someone I want to be friends with.
You're not someone I want to do business with.
You're not someone I really want to be spending
time with.
So I do sometimes ask to speak to the manager.
Uh, and I'm always extremely polite when I
do it.
Trying to think of the last time I had to
do something like, hey, it was just a bad
hotel.
I think it was, um, where was I?
I think it was when I was last in Montreal
a few months ago, there was a, the plumbing
stopped working multiple times at the hotel
and eventually I asked them, it wasn't like
a room issue.
I said, you know, I need to be able to get
in the shower and, and flush the toilet.
Um, I'm gonna need you to transfer us to a
different hotel and sort of like take care
of the arrangements.
Um, and they did and that was it.
And they apologized.
And a nobody, nobody was embarrassed or shamed
by me.
I just said, this is what we gotta do.
Uh, please treat everybody with kindness and
respect.
That's my, uh, that's my sign off today.
If you have a question you want answered,
let me know.
Ideally via email.
That's the most sort of personal and professional
way to let me know that you have a question
you want answered.
Use the contact usPage@davidpacman.com.
Great Bonus show for you today.
Coming up next if you are a member or a friend.
Otherwise, I will talk to you on Monday